it's May 1st 2020 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'm going to talk about what we've got
coming up in this very busy month of May
and what went on in April of 2020 I
always like to begin with three big
things so big thing number one is that
later on in the month we're not sure
exactly what the date will be because
they're still setting the schedule I
will be presenting as a keynote speaker
at an online conference on the
psychology of global crises so more
information about that later on big
thing number two we will be having the
second session of the classic metal
class that we got started this last
month of April and I'll tell you more
about that in the May section and then
big thing number three many of you may
know that I co host a radio show that
you can listen to live or on the
internet called wisdom for life and we
are now doing weekly episodes as opposed
to by weekly episodes me and my co-host
and Hayes so if you're interested in
practical philosophy and its
applications to improving our lives you
might want to check that out April has
been not just a busy but also a rough
month I think some of you may have seen
the video that I released yesterday a
kind of tribute to our 14 year old dog
Amica who was the last of our dogs who
we unfortunately had to put down it was
actually the the right decision for the
time but those things are always quite
difficult and so you know my wife and I
and our remaining four-legged family our
cat sassy are all kind of going through
the grief thing at this point in time
which will go on for quite a while
you know we've also been dealing with
all of the pivot to online education
stuff most of my classes were actually
online three of the five that I was
teaching but one of them is a prison
class where most of the students are in
lockdown so that presents its own
channel
and I have two other classes that had to
pivot online students who didn't sign up
for online classes who had to do mine
classes and so there's you know a good
bit of work involved in that I also had
quite a few events all of which of
course hurt online events because we're
not doing face-to-face anymore we held
the Milwaukee Sofia and Milwaukee stoic
fellowship meetings online through Xoom
I was also invited to do another
presentation for the stoah this time on
solitude and interior life so if you
want to see the video for that I'll put
the link down below in the video
description had my half-hour Haegele
sessions the public one for everybody
and the patreon exclusive one for people
at a particular level we had three
wisdom for life radio shows because we
did switch to doing the weekly radio
show so we had three instead of the
normal two in April I also did a
philosophy pop up specifically about
online education and and the pivot to
online I did my usual AMA what both you
know you can see the pop up and the AMA
link to below as well and we have the
first ever classic metal class as well
which was kind of a cool thing held that
using using zoom and doing a sign up for
it in advance so I could provide people
with some useful guides and we talked
about what classic metal is and why the
year 1970 is so important and how it's
bigger than just Black Sabbath and then
you know years and years later Judas
Priest coming on the scene there's all
of this stuff happening in 1970 and
running through 70 to 74 so you can see
the video for that as well if you'd like
to as I mentioned you know I I'm still
teaching classes this is the last week
for my students at Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design but we're still
chugging away with Carthage College
and Milwaukee Area Technical College as
well and I've been doing some some
writing working on some collaborative
work with some colleagues doing a lot of
editing of course for stoicism today and
some tutorial and philosophical
counseling work but what else went on
during during April well I turned away
with the podcast putting out not quite
every single day an episode but probably
at least five a week I'm guessing and
those were on some some william james
material the will to believe was really
cool essay by the way and quite a few on
Epictetus discourses i still have more
to convert with that but i got at least
I think 10 or 12 done and then I started
in on releasing the video there the the
podcasts rather made from the videos on
Cicero short work on fate which I
routinely teach in my classes as far as
videos go I didn't meet some of the
goals that I had about you know getting
back to shooting more half-hour Haegele
content or doing the book reviews in
part because of all the things that that
went on this month I did however create
two new unboxing videos again I'll link
to those below that some of you may have
gotten a kick out of one about receiving
a shipment of chalk which I need for
this chalkboard I was almost out and
another about getting a book that I
needed for for my my videos and for my
classes that included Cicero's on fate I
also did quite a few core concept videos
from my classes including some on
Alistair McIntyre's after virtue and a
number of them on Cicero's on friendship
and then there's of course the videos
from the online events that I mentioned
before link to below the AMA the pop up
the classic metal clasp the stoah
presentation so if you want to see those
you can just click the show more and
you'll you'll see them popping up for
you and then you can you're going to
watch them if you'd like
there are a lot of online events coming
up in May that you can watch listen to
participate in in one way or another all
the times that I'm gonna give you our
central time so if you're not in central
time zone you want to make sure that you
take account of the time difference
between where you are and where I am and
I'll start by talking about the radio
show which airs every Saturday 4:00 p.m.
central time wisdom for life if you want
to hear me and my co-host talking about
practical philosophy and interesting
topics and things that you can apply to
your everyday life and issues and
problems and you know we'll also
consider listeners questions if they
send them in to us then you want to tune
in and you can listen to that live like
I said on Saturdays or you can always go
back and listen to previous episodes
when I when I post them so that will be
on the 2nd the 9th at the 16th of 23rd
and the 30th because it's once a week so
5 episodes coming up in May the other
thing that we don't yet have a date for
is that keynote presentation at the
psychology of global crises conference
not quite sure what day it's going to be
or exactly what time so you want to look
at my social media or the reason I own a
vents calendar to get updated on that
what I'm going to be talking about is
complex causality and solidarity with
the vulnerable and I'll give you a just
a little bit of a preview of that so you
know when we talk about the the Cova de
19 crisis it's a crisis in part because
other things were screwed up and failing
and that's what that's part of what made
it into the crisis than it is that we're
experiencing and I think that I'm going
to make an argument that we really need
to think about how all these different
causes and effects coincide with each
other and about the need to focus on and
favor the most vulnerable rather than
the most privileged when we're thinking
about what we ought to be doing so
that again will find a date for that
sooner or later tomorrow on the second
I've been invited to the 52 living ideas
group to present a bit on stoic virtue
the good the bad and the indifferent
that will be happening at 1:30 p.m.
Central Time 2:30
then on the 5th at 6:00 p.m. we will be
having our Milwaukee Sophia that's the
Society of philosophers in America
chapter meeting anybody who wants to
come in is welcome you don't have to be
from Milwaukee because we're doing it
online and we'll be talking about again
how we can apply philosophy in our
everyday life so if you want to join it
on that you're perfectly welcome to and
then on the 9th at 12 p.m. I'll have my
monthly AMA that has asked me anything
session you want to make sure to get
there early and ask your question early
if you ask multiple questions I'm going
to skip over your questions I'll just
pick one because we get so many people
asking questions that I think it's only
fair to try to answer as many from as
many different people as I can then that
same day on the 9th at 2 p.m. I'll have
my philosophy chant which is a perk for
patreon supporters at a certain level
people who bring all of this to you by
underwriting the work that I do so if
you want to become a patreon supporter
and get in on philosophy chat where you
get to have you know sort of you know
video conferencing discussions with me
and talk about anything that you like
maybe you want to sign up on the 13th
another perk brought to you by patreon
supporters but open to everybody at 5
p.m. on the 13th is my public Haegele
Q&A and discussion session you can pop
in and ask me anything that you'd like
about Hegel German idealism philosophy
if people don't have questions and
usually we you know the regulars and I
chitchat about different topics but
anybody who wants to get you know some
some information about Hegel or that
leaves my speculations
welcome to join me for that on the 16th
at 12:00 p.m. we will be having session
two of classic metal class and that is a
sort of video conferencing seminar that
that I'll be leading and I'm very happy
to say my friend and colleague Scott
truly will be joining me again as a
special guest this time we're going to
be talking about what I call the Sabbath
purple Nexus which is how deep purple
and Black Sabbath not only functioned as
a catalyst and influence for all these
other bands but I actually brought in
you know important players and then sort
of spit out important players resulting
in a whole bunch of other bands forming
you know like white snake rainbow solo
acts like you know do and Ozzy and and
this whole scene that emerges out of all
these intersections and going back and
forth with Sabbath and deep purple so
that's that's going to be a great time
then on the 20th at 3 p.m. I've been
asked by Massimo Pigliucci to join him
as a guest in his Stowe Innova
organization their presentation and we
haven't decided quite yet what we're
gonna talk about we're kicking around
some ideas but and you know it's gonna
be a lot of fun he's a great presenter I
think that we'll have a lot of interest
and conversation about whatever it is
that we're gonna talk about it'll
definitely be about stoicism on the 28th
at 6 p.m. and others stomach thing the
Mk II that is Milwaukee stoic fellowship
we meet by zoom during the kovat crisis
and you don't to be from Milwaukee just
like with the Milwaukee Sophia anybody
who wants to join in is welcome so you
know it's our local chapter we have
quite a few regulars who pop in from our
chapter but we also have people coming
regularly from Des Moines and Orlando
and Tucson so so if you're from
somewhere else feel free to pop in and
then the last thing that we have is a
scheduled event is
xxx so the very end of May 12 p.m. I'll
be doing a video premiere of another one
of the you know self-directed study
videos it's about time I finally got to
Augustine so I'm gonna shoot that and
we'll premiere it at that time which
means that I will be doing live chat
answering questions or addressing
comments that people leave as they're
watching it so if you if you like that
sort of thing that interactivity you'll
want to put that on your calendar the
other things I mean I you know we're
gonna still be having classes going on
and I'm still gonna be doing a lot of
writing obviously we're still going
through you know dealing with the the
recent loss of ameica
all of that is still going to be
happening in in May and then I'll be
doing the podcast some more I'm gonna
try to shoot for actually releasing an
episode a day if I can we're gonna
finish up Cicero's on fate and then I
have some stuff that I need to get ready
for my students which means that it's
also getting ready for you so I'm going
to do some kohlberg stuff on moral
development some James Rachel's on moral
and cultural relativism and then launch
into Dostoevsky x' notes from the
underground and after I get through that
I'll probably do an opinion poll to see
what at what people want next in the
podcast so stay tuned for that later on
in the month videos this is gonna be a
month where I can hopefully start
getting ahead of the game on videos all
of the event videos will be of course
released but I'm gonna try to get back
to shooting my six half-hour Haegele
videos a month I do want to get this
half a heart Eagle project finished
someday you know and then I've got some
books to review I'll be doing some
videos on those I'll probably be doing
some personal videos as well people have
been asking me for for those and so when
I think they're appropriate I'll do that
still releasing videos on cicero's on
friendship that I created for my
students and early release to my patreon
supporters and I've got some videos on
James
magnetism lecture one that I'm going to
release some core concept videos on
David Humes inquiry regarding human
understanding that I think I need to do
and finally I want to read I want to
revisit canoes myth of sisyphus which I
I started shooting videos on when I was
teaching that existentialism class
online last summer I believe yeah last
summer and now I'm teaching it again in
the fall as a 15 week class so I didn't
get to shoot some of the videos that I
wanted to I'm gonna hopefully crank
those out this month and I might I might
do some other core concept videos but
that's already saying quite a lot so I
think that's you know enough to commit
to for the time being I hope that all of
you have a great month you know there's
a lot to do here and you know there's a
lot of activities going on so wherever
you happen to be in the world I hope
that you're safe and healthy and well
stocked up on things and that you can
join us for some of these online events
or you know look forward to the podcasts
and videos coming out later this month
you